bonjour je m'appelle lionel nassetta
j'ai 55 ans et je suis depuis sept ans
le directeur de la scène nationale de
saint quentin en yvelines pendant la
crise sanitaire qui l'attendent à une
activité à l'intérieur du théâtre
puisqu'on a eu si on prend juste l'année
2021 il y aura eu quatre mois de
répétition des kids artistique sur scène
mais on a pu organiser et nous adapter
pour organiser en nombre incroyable
spectacle hors les murs pour maintenir
des projets avec une multitude de
partenaires pour assurer une présence
des artistes sur le terrain dans les
ehpad dans l'est dans les hôpitaux dans
le onze zones rurales en milieu scolaire
je pourrais d'entrée demandé plus de
moyens
plus de moyens pour faire notre travail
je pense que aujourd'hui la question
n'est pas celle là c'est que la question
de la culture et de l'art entre dans le
discours dans le discours politique en
dehors même des questions économiques et
l'art et la culture c'est notre
ouverture vers l'imaginaire et si on
ferme cette fenêtre vers l'imaginaire la
vie deviendra rapidement un enfer
également un discours que j'entends
assez peu sur la complémentarité entre
le numérique et puis les arts vivants
comment est ce que la culture et l'art
chez soi tel qu'il a pu se développer
ces deux dernières années peut être
totalement complémentaire de la culture
et de l'art dans des lieux de spectacle